before the video starts i'm trying to
raise three hundred thousand meals for
one thousand families in pakistan
yemen somalia bangladesh born sisters
inshallah help us feed them this ramadan
to open and break their fast yeah it's
not a sin
to be yourself allah doesn't make
mistakes god created the lgbtq
plus fox 2. we're not saying that it's a
sin to be that either
we're just saying that it's a sin to act
upon your desires no matter
what they may be why is incest groups
not in the lgbtq catalogue not exactly
the same
they they have they should put eye in
there allah doesn't make mistakes what
you're doing is you're
saying that i'm like this
if you're going to tell me that me being
like this
is wrong allah made a mistake
how can we have so many devices with so
many apps which help us monitor our
progress for our body
but none for the soul well the quran the
app is about to show you
your progress with your soul yes that's
correct not only does it encourage you
to read it tells you how many verses
you've read how many pages you read how
long you've been on it and best of all
the hasanah counter
download the qurani app now and have a
ramadan with allah's book like
hope you guys are well inshallah i'm i'm
here i'm here
i'm here with the one and only zeeshan
he's been demasculinated
i've been emasculated hello
hello um did i tell the boy to say hello
hello i said that's the boy he
accomplished he's a boy
you shut up your mouth i'm doing the
video can you meet him please
you can come no you shut up please
what's this these are you know ali
figurines
okay this is is this haram yeah yeah
there's a character you know you're
drawing you know
no no yeah oh it's for you okay
is
as you can see as you can see he carries
in his pockets he probably got that out
of uh um
what's those eggs the chocolate eggs the
king the king
okay guys today we're going to be
reacting to something
somebody sent me i found it quite
interesting have you ever have you guys
ever heard of
blurry manny blurry money woman called
blair might
her name is blair imani yeah she's black
bisexual muslim
she her educator influencer historian
author
get smarter with i don't want to promote
that
so now there's a specific uh post that
she done i found
yeah yeah she's got so about nearly 400
000 followers yeah no no on instagram
instagram okay
okay yeah so okay i'm gonna go to this
one because this one i found really
interesting this one that was shared
with me yeah okay
so do you want to read the caption first
you read the picture um you do it yeah
okay no what are you doing these guys
rather like it okay so here it goes yeah
it's not a sin
to be yourself right
next one allah doesn't make mistakes
god created lgp lgbtqia
plus fox 2. now let's read the caption
dear religion religious leaders class
throat
the pope keep your arch archaic
interpretations
okay is that correct interpretations of
religious doctrine out of people's lives
amen many blessings to all the lgbtqia
folks that have been doing i mean
have been doing the important work of
existing and thriving while others try
to protect
hate and bias on to us thank you for
holding it down for queer people
of faith time for a queer role call okay
now i think these pictures in a nutshell
says a lot because let's just recap that
it's not sin to be yourself allah
doesn't make mistakes
god created lgb folks too when you see
that
is that is that the worst thing that's
on our account why did you decide for
those three
no someone sent that to me this specific
one and i found that to be very
troublesome
i think this is the very the crux of the
matter of everything stick to this here
because this is this is
this is where the fitness coming from
you go to the root of the fitnah not the
branches okay
what do you understand from that what
the argument is it's not it's not i'm
why is it sinful for me to be lgbqt i'm
born like this did allah make a mistake
are you telling that allah made him
basically saying if you have a problem
with me you have a problem with allah
you're saying that allah made a mistake
what would you say to that wait what
she's right she's giving dawa to us
what's the first one okay the first one
is look
it's not a sin to be yourself she's
right it's not a sin to be yourself
you know that's so she's strategic okay
look she's not making really a big
argument she's exactly you know what i'm
trying to say yes
she's doing it the way you're saying it
look allah doesn't make mistakes of
course he doesn't
god created those folks too yeah she's
right but you're saying that from the
from the theme of her channel she means
that it's not a sin to be yourself i.e
it's not sin to be lgbtq
yeah and we're not saying that it's a
sin to be that either
we're just saying that it's a sin to act
upon your desires no matter
what they may be it could be a desire of
the opposite gender it could be a desire
to eat something haram yeah a desire is
a desire and our job as human beings
people that have been created is
to curb those desires and work towards
pleasing allah
and that we've been told by the precepts
of sharia
yeah what's the second thing allah
doesn't make mistakes of course he
doesn't make mistakes in fact for
someone to even assume that he does
you've left the fold of islam and the
third one god created all folks yes just
like god created
the pig the pig is haram for us to
consume and we don't consume it
but it's not an argument that just
because god's created it therefore it's
halal
so if god's created an emotion or
something god's created anger it doesn't
mean we go around being angry
that's interesting actually because it
goes back to the qatar issue but that's
the whole difference of the
so hijab what is your take on it this
notion
of queer people of faith
what what is intended by it is my
question what is your intention here is
your intention to say that that ought to
be the case or that
allowing us to exist as if they're the
subject of
um they they could we're having a
conversation about their existence we're
not no one's
religious people are not having a
conversation as to whether
they should exist or not mm-hmm they're
recognizing
in the queer literature because i do
remember i wrote a book on this i spent
a whole year researching it called fifth
wave feminism there's this idea of the
impossible
where can we get this book on amazon
okay
will it be in the description i'm sure
he's going to put it there
he has to put it there but this idea of
the impossible
uh the impossible existence we're not
making an argument that they shouldn't
exist as human beings
but who told you that you should be
defining an entire group of people by
their sexuality anyway
because to be quite frank this this is
for me was one of the contradictions
post-modernism and post-structuralism
which is one of the things that they put
forward as
the framework for that's why they reject
for example by a lot of them reject
biological sex
forget about gender biological sex is
it de constructs meta-narratives
but the idea that you can be defined by
your sexuality or a group of people can
be compartmentalized and categorized as
such
itself is a problem um component of the
queer theory because
why is it that these group of people are
to be defined in this way
i think there's a very strong argument
defining somebody by their sexuality
when we are so much more exactly i don't
think this gets highlighted you know
what it is
and this is what i kind of argue in my
on my book especially because there's
something called intersection
intersectionality okay which is
something kimberly kimberly crenshaw
mentions in 1984 in her book and her
paper on the issue which is that we are
interlocking with different kinds of
things though not just one thing
so for example we have we have different
identification markers yeah
where men or for example religious
people
or it could be from a tribe or whatever
but it seems to me that the western
narrative especially
and she's part of it actually colonial
colonial western narratives
it takes that upon itself to decide to
prioritize to undermine the values
cross-culturally
yeah no what i'm saying is that it takes
upon itself to
prioritize identification markers
exactly so lgbtq
itself is a discriminatory
categorization based on post
post-structuralist and post-modernist
analysis which aims to deconstruct all
of this in the first place
if anything and this is the argument in
my book what they should be doing is
leaving it to people to define whatever
it is they believe
should be prioritized in the
hierarchization of identification
markers
but but to actually have this whole
category now of
lgbtq people of faith which is which is
a compartmentalization of sorts
is actually contradictory to the the
starting points or the post-modernist
and post-structural starting points
of the entire queer project in itself
okay you know what i take from this year
and i'm not sure yet it's
to me let me tell you it's very because
this this was like very like
like it's it's look it's not a sin to be
yourself okay
um firstly it's it's problematic
thinking from the very get-go yeah
okay and the second statement makes it
worse allah doesn't make mistakes
now when i hear that ikea it's not a sin
to be yourself allah doesn't make
mistakes yeah
this very notion this allah doesn't make
mistakes what you're doing is you're
saying that i'm like this
if you're going to tell me that me being
like this is wrong
allah made a mistake what is this
that's called the naturalistic fallacy
okay but but who does that remind you of
before we get to this yeah what happens
is that usually
and this is a fallacy that's outlined by
david hume and others right there is our
fallacy
yeah so let's assume for the sake of
argument that could the argument that
they try to make is that we're born
homosexual right yeah
so that we have some genetic
predeterminers or precursors that
kind of make us who we are which is
homosexual right
but just because you are x it doesn't
mean you should be x right and so this
is what david hume
outlines is the naturalistic fallacy so
if i'm born a certain way
does it mean i have to enact or act out
why i'm born
because for example if somehow one day
they discover that in my genes there's a
propensity to violence or psychopathy
yeah in fact psychopath is a great
example
yeah if someone's born a psychopath now
do does society say okay you're a
psychopath go ahead and kill him
yeah yeah yeah just because you're born
a certain way yeah and you have certain
pathologies or you have
certain tendencies temperaments or
dispositions it doesn't mean you have to
enact those
and the assumption of those of this of
this
god doesn't make sense is that the the
is should be the or but that's a logical
jump and it would be a naturalistic
fallacy on david hume's reasoning
yeah and and and rightly so exactly so
like like you said before
i concur yes um yes me too
it's a sin to be yourself like you said
before it can be somebody who has like
there's there's pedophiles who are
coming out and saying that they are born
that way but the lgbqt coming to her
community is
outright rejecting them and telling them
that's wrong yeah yeah they do so
so sorry they do so because they say
there's a harm principle i mean a lot of
them will say
with it with the child does the heart
okay okay but one thing i would want to
add
yeah one thing i keep mentioning this
right sorry to cut you off
why is incest groups not in the lgbtq
catalogue not exactly the same
they they have they should put eye in
there they should actually put eye on
their incest should be there
because on harm principles any harmful
support you like
a brother and a sister that are
consensually adult having sex
is is equivalent on the arm principle
than two men and two men there is no
difference
the only thing you can mention is
deformed babies sorry you can have oral
sex
you can have all kinds of you can put
contraception we're not living in the
fifth century anymore we can do those
things so why have the lgbtq community
not accepted incestuous relations
there's an eye in the but i don't know
what the eye is for
i don't think i i don't know i don't
think it's there but i don't know if
it's for that i don't think it's for
that so so the thing is then
it's it's like someone can come and say
i think that's going to be the next step
but the thing is for example it's like
she's like
they don't accept those people because
they believe you it's
just like no i just like it yeah so the
thing is it's like
it's like a person who wants to come
incest they can come and say
okay like you said before that give me
that right they would outright
say no no that's unnatural so who
decides what's unnatural and to me
what i really wanted to focus on was
this allah doesn't make a mistake here
because this is the one where allah says
in the quran have you seen the one who
takes his desires
on god because your principle here is
this i'm
born like this or whatever you don't
accept me like this
yeah allah made a mistake so it's not
i'm wrong
allah is wrong now who does that remind
you of i'm so sorry but that reminds me
of a police bill
i believe allah told him to it look it's
very similar
this person has a they should define
himself as a queer here
okay allah told at least to bow down to
adam because
allah
seven for the price of one yeah um so
the thing is
when shaytan refused why did he refuse
because he said
i'm better than him now what you do when
you say you're better than him you're
taking like your own
desires as your god because the moment
allah tells you don't do it you're
saying oh allah
but i'm like this yeah i'm i don't like
the fact that you're asking me to bow
down
to adam therefore you're wrong and
that's what exactly shaytan
that's why iblis fell into disbelief not
because he didn't bow down
because if that was the case then adam
alayhi salaam should also fall into
disbelief because he didn't even he
he ate from the tree allah told him not
to eat so if the
the issue was the sin that was committed
that leaves you at the foot of islam
adam alaihissalam would have left his
will but he ascribed the mistake to
allah
i'm saying no now when somebody rejects
something you're basically saying allah
you're wrong you made a mistake you're
ascribing a mistake to allah
so if you either accept me as me not
bowing down to adam
if you don't accept me like this you
made a mistake
so when i see this aki all i see with
this community
is that basically either you're going to
accept me the way i am
or i'm going to ascribe a mistake to
allah and say allah created me like this
and it falls into disbelief
so you can see i believe from this the
crux of the matter is
that the one who doesn't submit their
will to god almighty
and accept that whether however you're
born aki
i'm trying to say if i was born with i
don't know i had a desire of just
killing people or whatever it may be
yeah i have to fight that desire within
myself
i'm trying to say for the sake of god
but i could come and say no i don't get
i was created like this and i'm going to
do it and no one can
blame me in the context of the other
video that you did about sam harris yeah
you know i was created like this is a
hard
determinism and no one can blame me and
take me for account for the way i was
born do you know what i'm trying to say
so i just think guys in a nutshell if
you have these tendencies we've done
multiple videos on this
but you see the the methodology and the
mentality of these people
that they're basically saying you have
to accept me the way i
am and if you don't forget you like a
middle finger to you
yeah forget that i would go against the
one who created me and then i would
describe a mistake to him
that is the boundaries that's been
crossed and i think that was to me
that's why i took it but it was nice to
hear
from both of you as well that you came
from a different perspective and yeah
like i said before guys we are here to
worship god almighty
tahit and any kind of desires that you
have
you fight it off it's as simple as that
and that is what the connection between
you and your lord is
and allah tests you with different stuff
so that's why i wanted to do that video
and i believe
it's pathetic you know like seeing this
woman and how she's justifying it
etc is prophetic reasoning which we've
outlined and that's it
um until next time there's anything else
you'd like to say no thank you
bro sisters till next time assalamu
alaikum if you would like us to react to
more videos send them on my instagram
and we'll do it as
ishaan's house goodbye